in American Empire Andrew bacevich
offers his analysis of America's foreign
policy in the post Cold War era this
talk from the Carnegie Council in New
York City lasts an hour
I had the privilege to teach some of
those students it's great to see you
here and I also want to extend a special
welcome to its director James Chase
thank you James I also want to welcome
c-span and the viewers who through the
magic of television get to participate
in this exchange finally I don't get
this floor all that often and every time
I do I always want to thank Joanne
Meyers who's the director of the
Carnegie councils Merrill House programs
those of you who are regulars here know
that she does a fabulous job and I think
this is the best forum for these kinds
of discussions anywhere so Thank You
Joanne when I think of American Empire I
have two images in mind one of them is
etched in memory I was at an airport in
China in Beijing of all places before
they built the new airport the dank
dusty old Beijing Airport stranded there
with Professor chase on our way to
Shanghai why we didn't fly directly to
Shanghai I'll never know but anyway
there we were waiting for our flight
when a we struck up a conversation with
a French businessman I had a nice
conversation and shared some noodles
with him I believe toward the end of the
conversation he said he had an important
business call to make to the United
States and he couldn't remember the
country code at which points James
looked at him and said zero zero one
what else could it be the Frenchman was
not amused
then there's but there's another side in
James of all people will appreciate what
this this little this little story I'm
about to tell which is the other side of
the arrogance of power as a realist he
knows that there's a real danger of the
arrogance of power and this this little
dialogue was forwarded to me by a
Canadian friend it's a transcript of a
conversation from Canadian authorities
off the coast of Newfoundland in October
1995 and this was a transcript that was
released by the u.s. Chief of Naval
Operations and it's in dialogue form
first the Americans please divert your
course 15 degrees to the north to avoid
a collision
the Canadians response we recommend you
divert your course 15 degrees to the
south to avert a collision the American
response this is the captain of a u.s.
naval ship I say again divert your
course Canadian reply no I say again
divert your course now the Americans and
this is in bold letters with an
exclamation point at the end this is the
aircraft carrier USS Missouri we are a
large warship of the u.s. Navy divert
your course now the Canadian response
this is a lighthouse your your your call
well-well-well those are the two images
of the Empire and I know there's a
little bit of levity in both of those
stories but especially today and
especially in wake of what's happening
overseas I think and evasive which is
written and extremely extremely
important but this book was written last
year it was published last year and
we've had occasion to discuss it several
times and this is one of those books
that when I read it and I heard Andy
talk about it I said we absolutely have
to have him here and so I'm delighted
that he made time out of his busy
schedule to come
Andy's professor of international
relations at Boston University and he
runs their Center Center for
international relations and he's a West
Point graduate has his PhD from
Princeton in American diplomatic history
he writes often you've probably seen his
pieces in Foreign Affairs foreign policy
first things and Andy thanks for making
the time to come thank you thank you
very much for having me it's a it's a
real honor for me to have a chance to
speak to this distinguished audience and
it's always fun for me to get away from
Boston and come to the really big city
and and and discuss things I think my
task is to talk for about 25 minutes or
so and I'm counting on if I drag on to
tell me to keep quiet and I I hope that
after that we'll have a chance to have
some discussion and get your reaction
too to put it mildly we are right now
living in momentous times and so I
thought as I was thinking about this and
my way down on my very slow train that
rather than spending my 25 minutes
talking directly about the book
describing the book and me trying to
make a pitch to you to buy the book
although I hope you will I thought that
it might make more sense for me to offer
at least one observers reflections on
what's happening now that is to say some
reflections on the implications of
the war in Iraq and quite frankly I'll
do that in a way that does connect to my
book and in a sense I think I think what
I'm going to offer you in brief remarks
is an addendum to the last chapter of
the book the story I tell which is a
preliminary effort to describe u.s.
foreign policy in the aftermath of the
Cold War really ends with the conclusion
of President Bush's first year in office
much has happened just since that that
of course is not in my book so let me
reflect on that a little bit no this is
not a policy book this is not a book
that tells you what one guy thinks ought
to be rather this is a book that tries
to offer an interpretation of what is
and to invite readers to reflect on what
is because at least in my judgment
what is is problematic and the essential
point of the book and after this I'll go
on to talk about the war and its
implications
the essential point of the book is
captured by the title that we have like
it or not and I don't much like it we
have like it or not come to preside over
something like a global Empire and it is
time for us as citizens to begin to face
up to the implications of that very
large fact now it is anytime you write a
book you invest a lot in it not just
time and effort but you know something
of yourself but I hope it is more than
mere stubbornness that leads me to say
that the events that have transpired
since I wrote this book have only served
to persuade me that my understanding of
US foreign policy in the aftermath of
the Cold War is essentially correct so
with that as sort of the going in
position let's discuss what's happening
now
in the 1990s I argue in this book there
was a tendency on the part of American
policymakers to employ veiled language
to conceal the extent of American
ambitions to put it bluntly the people
in the policy elite were reluctant to
call a spade a spade
a couple of examples of that one that
made a bit of a splash at the time was
then forgotten but now has been revived
and has been written about quite a bit
lately was the controversy surrounding
the drafting of the defense planning
guidance of 1991 that's bush 1 Europe
and that document was drafted by a guy
who was very much in the news today
today's Deputy Secretary of Defence Paul
Wolfowitz who in 1991 was the
Undersecretary of defense for policy in
the elder Bush administration and this
document which will for what's drafted
and which was leaked in draft form to
the New York Times basically said the
following
we're number one we won the Cold War
there is only one superpower this is a
circumstance which is not only agreeable
but the perpetuation of this
circumstance ought to be the central
thrust of u.s. foreign policy from this
day onward well when that hit the press
in 1991 the reaction on the part of both
politicians and the media was that of
shock and horror that a senior US
official should so boldly propose the
notion of orienting American grand
strategy with an eye toward perpetuating
American supremacy and I dubbed this in
the book the Wolfowitz indiscretion
because it taught an important lesson to
others in the Bush administration and to
members of the Clinton administration
that followed and
was we don't say these things out loud
it is unseemly to talk about the United
States trying to perpetuate its
supremacy the second example they offer
in the book is what I called Albright's
rule and Albright's rule was the
creation of Madeleine Albright during
her time as Secretary of State you may
recall the very famous incident was one
of the times we were gearing up to
pummel Saddam Hussein in the ineffective
way that we did during the Clinton
administration and Albright and sandy
Berger and William Cohen went to Ohio
State University to make an appearance
before students and basically the
purpose of the appearance was to
quote-unquote make the case for war the
Madeline Albright didn't want to call it
war the student reaction was very
negative and there the the Clinton
people were getting heckled and at one
time Madeleine Albright sort of spit out
we're not talking about war we're
talking about the use of force and this
was very much part of the 1990s we
didn't like to talk about war you may
recall the Kosovo war of 1999 which was
a 77 day bombing campaign which to come
to an administration never called a war
Albright's rule said we weren't supposed
to do such things well point number one
that I would make with regard to the
current circumstances is that both the
Wolfowitz and discretion and the
Albright's rule both of them have been
repealed and now for better or worse and
it may actually be for better we've
begun to say out loud what our
intentions genuinely are in in that
regard does nothing more important and
you all should read perhaps already have
the Bush administration's national
security strategy which was published
last September available on the White
House website a document that makes
quite explicit our intention to maintain
our global dominance Wolfowitz his view
is back that now has the Imperato of the
President of the United States and of
course the whole
we don't do war has also gone by the
board we do make war of course now we
marry that to the language of liberation
so that our Wars of course are virtuous
indeed when I wrote this book and my
publisher Harvard University Press quite
frankly persuaded me to call that
American Empire it was with the thought
that that's gonna be a catchy title
that's gonna irritate people it is
remarkable to me it's remarkable the
extent to which words like Empire
Imperium phrases like Pax Americana have
now insinuated themselves into public
discourse and are no longer
controversial so the veil has dropped
since 9/11 we see it in the war that's
going on right now and I think that's a
very important recent development that I
would add on to that last chapter were
right to expand it point number two
point number two has to do with the
militarization of u.s. foreign policy
which I would cite as a major theme of
of American Empire it is remarkable it
was remarkable to me at least the extent
to which the United States came out of
the Cold War into an era in which we no
longer faced a major threat and that
meant the response to that with regard
to the use of force was if our greater
willingness to use force and who paved
the way in that tendency the guy who
paved the way in that tendency was the
individual whom one active duty US Air
Force general officer referred to as
that dope-smoking skirt-chasing
draft-dodging fella who was in the White
House in the 1990s Bill Clinton Clinton
led the way in in removing the barriers
with regard to the use of force and it's
not just the use of force of course is
too
all of us defense spending fareed
zakaria had a piece called the urgant
empire cover story in Newsweek what two
or three weeks ago and just glancing
through that I noticed at least by his
calculation I haven't checked his
arithmetic his calculation the United
States spends more on military spending
than every other nation in the world
combined I do believe that is
historically unprecedented but that's
not really the surprising bit the
surprising bit is that for those of us
who are Americans that fact is utterly
uncontroversial of course of course so
in the aftermath of the Cold War the use
of force the maintenance of force the
perpetuation of American military
supremacy have come to be very important
themes and of course recent events have
simply reinforced that and reaffirmed
that again I refer you back to the Bush
administration's national security
strategy which strikingly promulgates a
doctrine of preventive war and warns
explicitly against any other nation
thinking that it can exercise a similar
prerogative and it's not just talk of
course it's action because the war
against Iraq is a preventive war it is a
war of choice it is not a war that is
forced upon us it is a war that we have
chosen to undertake so the
militarization of American foreign
policy continues in the period following
the period covered by my book so much so
that I at least am convinced all the
more so what
said in the book is correct and that is
that the exercise of military power yes
has become the preferred instrument of
American national power
the third point the third point has to
do with the exercise of American global
leadership and you can almost put that
phrase in quotes that's that is when you
familiar it survives I argue in the book
that one expression of American global
leadership has been a determination that
the United States will maintain a
dominant position let us use the
political science ii term hegemony in
any region of the world that the United
States views as strategically
significant now it's not that this is
some some recent development I mean
during the course of the 19th century
the United States determined that having
a dominant position in the Western
Hemisphere was essential to our
well-being in security and by the time
1898 rolls around we had secured that
and we have maintained that ever since
in the aftermath of World War two this
bloody mess the United States had
decided that a dominant position in
Western Europe and a dominant position
in East Asia were also essential to our
well being and we devoted a tremendous
amount of attention energy resources to
include a couple of East Asian Wars in
an effort to maintain those positions as
we have down not down to the present day
against you know it's among those facts
that as Americans we have we so take for
granted that we don't even notice them
more than a half century after the end
of World War two when I would argue no
security threat exists that threatens
the well-being of Western Europe we
still maintain hundred thousand troops
in and we don't even think about well
the end of the Cold War focused
attention on a yet another region and
that was a Persian Gulf and in the
Persian Gulf War of 1991 the elder
President Bush thought that he had
secured American hegemony in that
strategically important region but it
turned out in the course of the 1990s
that our hold in the Persian Gulf
was quite uncertain we miscalculated
about the impact of the first Persian
Gulf War and it turned out to Saddam
Hussein had survived it turned out that
maintaining a troop presence in the
Persian Gulf and a somewhat smaller
scale than we did in Asia and in Europe
did not have the same stabilizing
effects on the contrary that a
destabilizing effect as the attacks on
Khobar towers on the American embassies
in Africa on the USS Cole suggested that
is to say the US presence created a
backlash all of which ended up setting
the stage of course for the present war
the removal of Saddam Hussein and I
would suggest to you in all likelihood
the conversion of Iraq into not simply a
bastion of pro-american sentiment but a
new base for operating American military
power intended to secure hegemony for
good now in the Persian Gulf and oh by
the way you would say parenthetically
since the end of the Cold War
the United States is also established at
least a foothold in yet another region
Central Asia
now will that result in an effort to to
maintain hegemony they're hard to say
but a development that we really ought
to continue to watch fourth point I
think I talked a lot in this book about
what I call a strategy of openness
really an effort to inculcate norms
favorable to us our norms our values as
a prerequisite for security American
security and American and indeed global
prosperity up to 9/11 the Arab world was
given a waiver on this notion of
adhering to American norms I mean you
you you know the basic relationship
between ourselves and the Arab nations
particularly the Arab nations of the of
the Persian Gulf they got security we
guaranteed it we got oil we not simply
the United States but the developed
world and we both got stability in the
course of that of course Arab notions of
governance pretty much got ignored no
longer no longer because the current war
really doesn't end in Baghdad does it
Baghdad is really the first phase in a
larger effort which the Bush
administration is now clearly signaling
intended to fix a problematic part of
the world through modernization
liberalisation and an openness yeah I'll
give it this is this is this is your
dramatic reading
when I'm talking about this strategy of
openness and I talked about how it
didn't apply
to the Middle East after 1991 US troops
garrison the Persian Gulf not to pry the
region open to American enterprise and
American values but to prop up the
status quo but only temporarily in due
course the opportunity to open the Arab
world would present itself for if as
members of the American policy elite
insisted with year near unanimity and I
had been citing these members of the
policy elite if as they insisted with
near unanimity democracy market
principles and globalization were indeed
sweeping the world than existing regimes
in key states like Egypt and Saudi
Arabia we're living on borrowed time
when it became expedient to do so and I
would insert parenthetically it has
become expedient to do so when it became
expedient to do so senior US officials
could be expected to unveil all the
truths that the White House and the
State Department had for many years
chosen to soft-pedal or ignore that
these regimes were deeply corrupt denied
civil liberties engaged in wholesale
violations of human rights and
resolutely opposed anything even
remotely resembling popular rule that is
what we know places like Saudi Arabia
and Egypt to be when they went few
members of the American foreign policy
establishment would lament their demise
virtually all would applaud the opening
of the region to democratic capitalism
that would presumably ensue and I would
tell you that the words that I wrote
back in about the year 2000 are now
coming to pass and we will hear much
about the need of the Saudis and the
Egyptians to be more cognizant of human
rights and the like and they ought to be
fifth point I'm not as cynical as you
may think me to be based on these
remarks I'm actually a pretty idealistic
fellow but I argue in this book and I
think it is true and I think we're
seeing the truth today that when it
comes to American statecraft despite all
our talk about American idealism ideals
really matter
only when they coincide with US
interests and indeed I argue in the book
that in the 1990s in most of the
military interventions undertaken and
Bill Clinton's watch that were justified
of course as humanitarian interventions
Bosnia Kosovo Haiti were in fact driven
and shaped by consideration
considerations of self-interest and I
would say today on the first day of the
liberation of Baghdad and the liberation
of the Iraqi people and that liberation
is real and it should be applauded by
any decent human being that that has
occurred not because of our concern for
the Iraqi people but it occurred because
of American strategic economic and
political self-interest that is to say
liberation is real but it's a byproduct
the war to bring down Saddam Hussein is
no more motivated by a desire to free
the Iraqi people than the war to bring
down Hitler was motivated by a
determination to free those in the death
camps we may wish that that's why we
fought that war in World War two we may
wish that the reason we're doing what
we're doing in Iraq is to free oppress
people but it's simply not the case
that is to say don't expect to see
operation Burmese freedom happen anytime
soon
the people of Burma deserve to be freed
and quite frankly if one would take
seriously the idealistic rhetoric of
that Bush administration national
security strategy then we ought to be
sending our aircraft carriers to Burma
next nor will there be any effort to
liberate the people of Zimbabwe to free
them from the yoke of oppression of
Robert Mugabe nor are we likely to see
any regime change
anytime soon in Havana and my point of
saying all this is simply that let us
celebrate let us celebrate the
achievement of American men and women in
uniform and extraordinary military
campaign that they have fought let us
celebrate the fact that the people of
Iraq are indeed free today of a tyrant
and we hope we wish them well but let's
not allow ourselves to become
intoxicated on the vapors of the
idealistic rhetoric that we spout in
order to find an idealistic rationale
for doing something that we actually do
for quite other reasons one last point
if I may but one more so about three
three minutes
and I don't write about this in the book
I don't think I do events going on today
now in this time I think affirm this
important fact that we will never again
be a normal nation there are a lot of
people here roughly my age and some a
little bit older meaning you are of the
Cold War when I was a kid growing up in
the 1950s and even in the 1960s
understanding in some vague way that
this thing called the Cold War this
danger called communism this this
ominous threat called the Soviet Union
needed to be addressed needed to be
confronted for some vague reason I don't
know why it also there was this little
notion in the back of my mind that even
though I had no conception of when these
problems would go away that when they
went away whenever that was - the United
States would once again become a normal
nation I didn't even know what normal
meant but but I knew that I thought I
knew that the exertions of the Cold War
were out of the ordinary
and we'd revert to some sort of status
quo I was thinking on the way down when
I was a kid in the 1950s
what would the word Baghdad have meant
to me would have meant Arabian Nights
would have meant flying carpets it would
have meant something so exotic that what
it would be utterly alien the stuff for
Disney cartoons Baghdad that's a kid in
the 50s what would I've thought of the
word Afghanistan which clearly I would
not have been able to identify in a man
I think in the 1950s Afghanistan would
have been for me in the same category of
as a name place
Siberia Mongolia
distant desolate far far away from
anything that would have to do with me
now think about it today all right we
know because we've been living through
these events we know we know how things
came to be in a sense that we know it
happened yesterday and the day before
and the day before and so we know why
were in Afghanistan we know why we're in
Baghdad but think about it American
soldiers invading baghdad
to stay for how long
american soldiers fighting in
afghanistan a place that if it has any
meaning at all is a place where empires
clash and again in a sense we know how
we got here but i would say if you step
back from it a little bit at least a
fear of my generation and think about it
you really cannot help but be astonished
and quite frankly you cannot reach any
conclusion about what's going on other
than the fact that we are the new rome
we do preside over a global empire we do
have a militarized foreign policy and
there probably is no escape so i thank
you very much and I look forward to
entertaining your comments
well thank you Andy as you can see this
isn't just just a book a book of
research and analysis but handy put a
lot of himself into it we really
appreciate you sharing that with us in
your thoughts I'm gonna go directly to
questions now I'm gonna ask you to
please raise your hand identify yourself
and then please wait for the microphone
to arrive before you start your
questions and we've got about 15 minutes
or so and then we'll have our reception
oh I'm sorry this gentleman here and
then we'll come over here yes thank you
Harlem lesson if your analysis is
correct and it certainly is logical
then the self-interest of the United
States who would seem to be on a
hegemonic basis also relative to Iran
and perhaps other countries which don't
under the same category as Cuba or as in
Bob Wayne do you foresee the United
States interests being sufficient to
cause us to enter into our own interest
of military efforts in those countries
this is what I think's going on right
now
this isn't this administration is deeply
divided in many respects and if we could
if we could call it it's unfair it's too
simplified but let us call the two camps
the Powell camp and the Wolfowitz camp
we call it the bull Floyd's camp despite
the fact that he's number two in defense
but in recognition of the fact that he
seems to be the intellectually the
driving force of of what I I would label
the imperialists Powell much more
cautionary in his views or cautious
Powell lost this round quarterly Paul
was a good soldier
Powell continued to serve his president
but having lost the first round doesn't
mean that all subsequent rounds are lost
my sense is that the imperialists wanted
to go get Saddam for a whole variety of
reasons but ultimately because
is the imperialist strategy the strategy
of cementing American hegemony in the
Persian Gulf pursued not not for any
sort of sordid cynical reasons like oil
in particular yes oil always figures but
pursued because they are determined to
ensure that 9/11 doesn't happen again
and for people in the imperial camp the
two big numbers to emerge from
seven-eleven or what fifteen and
nineteen fifteen and nineteen there were
nineteen hijackers fifteen of them came
from saudi arabia that is to say the key
fact is conditions in that part of the
world breed people who hate the United
States of America and are willing to die
in order to kill us and so the the
strategy aims to bring about the
transformation of this region to remove
these conditions again to open it up to
inculcate our norms so the terror won't
come from there Iraq is step number one
Wolfowitz for example has said others
have said it's it's common now we intend
to make it rock the first functioning
era of democracy and I think there is
consensus in the administration on that
score where there is not consensus is
how do we get to step two three four
five and six because those do require
opening up Saudi Arabia opening up Egypt
opening up Syria opening up Iran and the
methods that are employed are going to
be dependent upon the particular case
certainly the hope would be the optimist
the most optimistic scenario is that
when the people of other Arab nations
and those of Iran see that Iraq prospers
Iraq is democratic Iraq is free that
that will encourage liberal tendencies
from the bottom up
in these other societies and that those
liberal tendencies will force repressive
leaders to adapt change that's a nice
thought I am NOT optimistic the
pessimistic scenario is one that says
that the leadership resists the
requirement to change perhaps the
leadership crushes the forces that are
advocating change from within which of
course would provide an opportunity to
do what to declare our solidarity with
the people of fill-in-the-blank and to
use our superior military power I'm
actually working on an outfit I don't
get it done and the op-ed is operation
parentheses insert name here parentheses
closed freedom because I think that's
where what's we're engaged
Michael volchok volchok consulting at
the beginning of your talk he talked
about what has led to the increasing use
of force since the end of the Cold War
and you laid most of it at the door the
Clint administration and I wonder what
you think about the first Persian Gulf
War being a major reason that has led to
the increased use of force obviously it
sort of demonstrated much lower costs of
us using our military right you are
correct and indeed in the book I did I
did just say that and it's a major theme
of the book but but this this tries to
tell the story of u.s. foreign policy
basically from 1990 to the year 2001 and
yes I tried to give due credit if that's
what it is to the elder Bush who of
course launched us it was that was the
first long now forgotten episode of the
post Cold War era
Panama somebody didn't forget all right
very interesting reassertion of American
dominance in this hemisphere instead of
a reminder all right but yes that was
then followed by the Persian Gulf War
and certainly the what seemed to be the
enormous success of Desert Storm and I
phrase it that way for
reason encouraged tendencies to include
tendencies on the left to now believe
that force had become much more useful
I mean Bush was Bush the elder was
certainly correct in arguing that now
we've kept the Vietnam syndrome as a
result of that now I say seemed like a
great victory because of course in
retrospect we would most I think
observers would argue that a Desert
Storm was a deeply flawed victory that
has probably led us down a path that got
us where we are today and it's been a
bloody path and may well be a bloodier
one still can you reach him yeah I'm
sorry Steve can you just show Steve have
them in Time magazine it's hard to argue
with the facts that you've laid out
which suggests the birth of the renewal
perhaps of the American Empire but what
makes me a little bit skeptical is that
it ignores some of the changes that have
happened since the Cold War ended in
other parts of the world which suggests
that not everybody particularly our
interlocutors are as likely to submit to
our definition of an empire as they
might have been maybe a hundred years
ago with Britain or others and added to
that is the real question of whether
this concept of an American Empire in
the Bush administration bush - and as
you said it began perhaps with Clinton
raises the question you would at last
passed the current Clinton limit with
the current Bush administration so how
how deep is this really and how much
kind of survive the number of other
organizations and coalition's that are
out there okay the world I mean it is
certainly a major theme of my book
which one I mean one you'll have to read
it to either be persuaded or not is to
argue that there's far more continuity
than discontinuity between
administration's that to pick on Time
magazine you guys for all kinds of good
reasons want to see difference
I want to argue difference in
discontinuity and it's not that that's
not legitimate and it's not that that's
not illuminating to a degree but my
argument is that that doesn't really
tell the story the real story of u.s.
foreign policy comes in seeing the
extent to which liberals and
conservatives Republicans and Democrats
by and large think alike talk alike and
act alike again you'd have to sort of
take stock of it yourself
opposition yes indeed I mean one of the
reasons that for me it's important to
say we're an empire faced up to it
because it's ain't gonna come for free I
mean gracious sakes we see that in the
events that are now unfolding and you
are certainly correct in my judgment
that the the way we wield our power if
it is done in a way that comes across as
arrogant if it comes across in a way
that does not take into account the
concerns and needs of those we've groups
we view as part of our Empire results
gonna be to increase the likelihood of
opposition and certainly that's the
problem with old Europe today I mean one
could argue I would argue that in the
nineteen first of all back up why why
did how is it that we became the hegemon
in Western Europe how did we come to be
the nation that says we are the leading
European power we're not even in Europe
I came about as
of World War two but it came about in
the aftermath of World War two because
the Europeans wanted yet somebody's
written a book called Empire by
invitation the French wanted us
the Brits wanted us the Germans wanted
us and they wanted us there they wanted
us to be the guarantor of their security
and the American Empire in Europe
produced what it produced it's certainly
strongly contributed to the emergence of
a Europe today is peaceful and is
affluent and is democratic and all
that's good we get to the end of the
Cold War and I think that even in Paris
European statesmen said to themselves
their calculus calculus was well okay
there's only one superpower left what
kind of world is that going to be I
think they concluded that it was a world
that they could live with an expectation
that at least be able to nudge the
Americans or perhaps restrain the
Americans from time to time and that
Americans basically shared their views
and were sensible people and that a
world in which America was the sole
superpower would be a world good for
Europe too and I think that the events
since 9/11 have now called that into
question hasn't made them change their
mind but what they see now is a nation
which again has committed itself to a
doctrine of preventive war and I truly
believe that President Bush is genuinely
persuaded that that doctrine is in the
interests of the United States of
America I also think it scares the
bejesus out of the Europeans and we now
have shown that with regard to the
United Nations Security Council and I am
no apologist for the United Nations at
all but with regard to the United
Nations Security Council we don't care
what they say when we see a requirement
to use force in a major way we're gonna
do it
so I think people like shurok face a
huge problem now there are those who
argue that the European response is
going to be given their affluence given
the size of the population that will see
the emergence of a counterweight I am
skeptical about that I'm skeptical
because they haven't figured out what
language their army is going to speak
they manifestly do not have the will to
spend sufficient money on defense to
create any kind of a counterweight and
quite frankly they're not even they're
not even procreating at a sufficient
rate to have enough young people to be
in an army so huge dilemmas given the
kind of society they have become but
they are deeply frightened and I think
trying to figure out whether or not they
are willing to live in a world in which
there is one superpower that basically
calls the shots okay we're running up
against time but we did start late so
I'm gonna gonna keep going for just a
little bit more that's alright and those
of you who have to leave we understand
but we're just gonna go a few more
minutes Christian said that you are in
fact a bit of an idealist so I'm gonna
ask you to indulge your idealism since
most of the account you gave was at
least a descriptive realist account of
what's going on and namely what keeps
you from being a prescriptive realist
that is do you see adjust and also
politically feasible alternative to this
hegemonic picture and what might that
look like because then we might not be
so quick to applaud much as we may be
happy for the Iraqis this war which many
seem to think really represents the
effective elimination of any kind of
cosmopolitan alternative to a hegemonic
governance the the question is why am I
not prescriptive yeah and the answer is
because I can't figure out the answer I
mean I am imitating I am an idealist in
this sense I'm an idealist or not in the
sense that I believe in this republic I
love America
I love I am enamored with the vision of
the founders of this Republic who set
out to create something that was new and
special and some of what was going to be
special about America was that this
would be a place in which war and
military power and power politics and
Dominion all those things those things
that were like plagues in the old world
they wouldn't be here in the new world
and I'm an idealist in a sense that it
makes me very sad that as a people we
have lost sight of that and we are
becoming something that at least in my
judgment people there are people who
vehemently reject his view we have
become something that I think would
appall the founders having said that I
have no idea how having mounted this
tiger we can now simply say let's get
off so although my heart says I wish
that we could not be an imperial power
my head says I think we're stuck with it
and being stuck with it means that we
begin we have to try to address some
difficult questions and not not to let
the people in Washington tell us what
the answers to those questions are but
as citizens to engage these things for
example
I was a serving officer for 23 years I
don't know what you think of the
American military today it's obviously
immensely capable there's nothing like
it
it's also a professional military it is
a military which is increasingly
detached from the American people and
quite frankly we like that we'll send
these guys over there and these gals and
we'll applaud them but we don't get our
hands dirty well this is this is an a
remarkable abandonment of a tradition of
citizen soldier ring that was part of
who we were is it a good thing to have a
professional army
maybe it's necessary if you're gonna
govern an empire on the other hand we
once thought that standing army was a
threat to Liberty could that be the case
now are you confident that it's not
would it surprise you to know that the
officer corps is now significantly
politicized and defines itself as
conservative in votes Republican said
good or is that bad
I'm a conservative but I don't think
it's good that an officer corps has a
political point of view so these are
things we need to think about seems to
me how how can we assure that the
American policy has to somehow take
moral considerations into account and
quite frankly self-interest says that
when you govern an empire you have to
take moral considerations into account
or the natives get restless
how do we do that given our reluctance
to spend our resources for purposes of
development that's a very clear part of
who we are as a people today defense
budgets up near four hundred billion
dollars a year but if somebody says
let's actually spend money to fix the
problems of the world it's oh no that's
a black hole that's foreign aid that's a
waste we need to
visit those things I think well on the
point of realism and idealism I have to
actually I just want to give the floor
to James Chase who's spent we've had
about ten year conversation on this on
this very topic as ID lists but realists
can you can you help us out James I love
the question for a first okay any base
of itch because I'm very much in
agreement with you the empires here to
stay like it or not I mean we have to
therefore deal with the reality this is
the reality if that's so I want to push
them further if I may on truth
internationalism and on relationships
with traditional allies in the past as
you know what we've had arguments with
the allies but no the Pershing missiles
and everybody knows a big problem there
and there is he but it's always been
sort of patched over one another always
strains after all I'm wondering if this
isn't different this is not a question
of a strain it doesn't mean that the
Tony Blair may think he's gonna be a
bridge but I don't think he's gonna be a
bridge to anything so I asked that
question how far do you think this is
gonna go do you think this is a way back
um well I hope there is and I again I I
don't know if Tony Blair is a bridge but
it does seem to me that that's the
crucial relationship we were talking
about this with some of my students this
past week and you are all the more
impressed that the special relationship
with Great Britain is something that is
vital to us and therefore if Tony Blair
comes and says I need help on making
this occupation look like a UN operation
or something of that notion it seems to
me that it is very much in our interest
to to be forthcoming because I do fear
that the breakdown could be
irretrievable with Europe the only
reason I would say I'm not certain as a
breakdown is because I think Europe's
choices from Europe's perspective are
lousy I mean again if they're not part
of the Empire I'll be a you know a
willing part then what are they and how
much is it going to cost them and are
they willing to give up you know
six-week long vacay
in Morocco in order to pay the cost of
of being of shapingg of creating a
European power okay thank you very much
Andrew bacevich is author of American
Empire the realities and consequences of
US diplomacy it's published by Harvard
University Press on the web at HUP
harvard.edu